dernier coup de pinceau après deux mois
de travaux à l'école victor hugo de
dijon les dix salles de classe se
métamorphosent les unes après les autres
du sol au plafond le maire françois
rebsamen fait le tour des écoles pour
constater l'ampleur des rénovations avec
une idée en tête il faut maintenant agir
sur l'ensemble de nos écoles par un
bilan énergétique voire celles qui sont
mal orientés mal protégé puisque je le
disais les périodes de fortes chaleurs
se sont produites pour la première fois
vraiment pendant le temps scolaire
avant elle se produisait en juillet août
mais maintenant avec les dérèglements
climatiques on peut pas écarter l'idée
qu'ils en aient des périodes comme celle
là en juin il ya même des villes qui ont
fermé les écoles la rénovation
énergétique est devenue une priorité
les deux écoles lamartine en sont le
meilleur exemple toiture isolation
extérieure ventilation le chantier de la
maternelle se terminera fin septembre
à la clé une école parer contre la
canicule et 30 % d'économie d'énergie
l'objectif initial
à l'époque c'était oui c'était plus dans
l'idée de dépenser moins - pour pour
l'énergie et aujourd'hui c'est plus pour
se protéger de la chaleur et du froid
mais du coup quoi qu'il en soit il y
aura aussi un effet forcément sur les
dépenses en matière d'énergie c'est
obligatoire d'autres solutions existent
pour faire baisser les températures
ressenties par les élèves
la végétalisation des murs et
l'engazonnement des cours d'école ont
commencé lundi
la rentrée sera un peu plus verte